hello there guys and welcome to another
video in this video we have been given
the first look at the mandalorian season
3 in the form of a set leak so it reads
here exclusive set photos and video of
our unknown mandalorian has been spotted
on set of the mandalorian season 3 along
with what appears to be an ice planet on
friday we were fortunate enough to get
some pictures and a video of the man
lauren set that train y'all din jiren
was spotted in full costume however it's
unlikely to be pedro pascal in the suit
as he's been spotted multiple times over
the past week in canada filming for the
last of us however guys that we're able
to snap some pictures of what appears to
be a new unknown mandalorian onset
unfortunately they were too far away to
get a clear picture of what the actors
faces but from what we can see here
looks like he's wearing a green and
brown armor you can also see a jet pack
he has so obviously this is definitely a
new mandalorian um different armor to
what we have seen in the previous
seasons this makes me think you know how
much more mandalorian characters will we
get will there be a big uprising of
mandalorians will dim john bring
together the surviving mandalorians or
you know there's just so much
speculation happening right now we don't
have too much information a lot of the
information we have is through these
leaks like the set leak that we have
here and also part of this leak they
also spotted what appeared to be a fake
ice or snow for the set they were using
so this leads us to believe that in this
show they'll be visiting another snow
and ice planet like we saw in the
previous season so i wonder what's going
to happen there so yeah that's about it
for this video just a short video on the
first look of the mandalorian season 3
which is through the form of a leak
they just started filming recently so
don't expect any trailer anything of
that kind however disney plus day is
coming up very shortly so hopefully
we'll get like uh some sort of behind
the scenes sizzle reel for the man loan
season three that would be pretty sweet
and get the hype roll in but yeah in the
meantime this is pretty much all the
information we have so if you want more
videos of me covering leaks or just any
information regarding the man loan
season 3 tell me in the comment section
below and if you enjoyed please like and
subscribe thanks for watching guys
[Music]
you